rendre compte des effets da proche
littoral de limites c'est là tout le
sens de l'oeuvre de jean pierre renaud
quant à encre rencontre l'eau un paysage
se profile et le voyage commence
travailler sur les florescence entre le
5 et mouillée et donc saisi florescence
sont donnés des paysages cet artiste
plasticien tourangeau est très influencé
par son environnement qui lui a inspiré
des techniques bien particulière tu
simple je prends des feuilles jeux wii
une partie de la feuille et je fais des
traits à l'homme de chine avec un
pinceau et donc je repère comment se
développe le l'efflorescence si les
matières ses fleurs se mélangent ou
serez pulsé grâce à l'encré chinoise à
l'eau tourangelle et au sable des plages
etc sur le papier parfois millimétré que
la proche de ses rivages à la fois
artistique mais également scientifique
prend forme à l'origine de travail et un
peu mathématiques et tourne autour de la
psychanalyse et à partir des
problématiques qui se dégage de ce ces
deux champs je fais des expériences des
recherches plastiques en fait c'est fait
c'est un clin d'oeil à la scientificité
la création n'est pas utile à l'artiste
elle y est nécessaire comme autant de
recherche décliné en plusieurs séries
encre de chine gouache fine
installations végétales et minérales qui
aiguille sa quête c'est quand même la
littéralité c'est quand même le bord le
bord de la mer
elle est l'égérie redécouvrez la
touraine et ses rivages haut en couleurs
le temps d'une exposition